halo's co-creator has reacted to
infinite resident evil 4 vr is launching
on the oculus quest 2 and bastion and
sombra are receiving some major reworks
for overwatch's next game i'm persia and
this is your gamespot news the reactions
to halo infinite multiplayer are
steadily pouring in after this past
weekend and one of those people who
shared their thoughts is marcus letto
the co-creator of the halo universe and
the designer of master chief leto said
he had a great time playing infinite
over the weekend going on to praise its
combat and map designs combat is fresh
yet familiar and the game looks
fantastic beautiful map designs too leto
said leto's position on halo infinite
has seemingly improved over time as he
previously said he was pretty worried
about the state of the game after 343
showed off its less than thrilling
campaign demo back in 2020. the next
halo infinite beta test is gonna start
on september 30th and it's going to show
off some big team battle action which
i'm pretty excited for if you want to
try to get your hands on that then
there's still time to sign up for the
halo insider program on halowaypoint.com
so good luck
oculus has announced that resident evil
4 vr is coming to the quest 2 on october
21st just in time for spoopy season this
version completely reimagines the
classic title and provides a brand new
way to experience it it also supports
full motion and teleportation movement
and it changes how players interact with
items players can directly grab items
from their own body such as the gun on
their belt the knife from the holster on
leon's chest or a health pack that's on
their left shoulder as with many vr
games reloading is done manually and
under a lot of pressure with creatures
trying to eat your face puzzles in the
typewriter save spots have been
recreated in the vr space too the game's
inventory system also allows players to
move their items around physically
however cut scenes are presented on a
theater screen instead of first person
and actions like climbing ladders or
jumping through windows are in third
person
the vr version of resident evil 4 was
revealed back in april but if vr isn't
quite your thing then a remake of the
game was rumored to be in the works
right now while its release date is
still nowhere to be seen blizzard is
finally starting to reveal some of the
character reworks and other details that
you can expect for overwatch too brand
new gameplay was revealed showcasing the
changes to sombra and bastion sombra the
game's hacking fiend potentially has the
more contentious changes among the duo
overall she'll be able to go on the
assault more often thanks to some
serious buffs to her hack ability which
now refreshes every 3 seconds enemies
who are hacked still can't use their
abilities although that's just for a
single second after being hacked for the
duration of the hack though which lasts
8 seconds targets are highlighted and
can be seen through walls hack targets
also take a whopping 50
more damage from sombra giving the
character a mean one-two punch of
hacking a target then peppering them
with bullets similarly sombra's ultimate
has been changed while it no longer
disables shields it deals damage to any
enemies in its radius for a total of 40
off their current health naturally any
enemy caught in the blast is also hacked
so sombra can easily take down enemies
she hits sombra's changes are a series
of buffs and nerfs but bastion has
largely been reworked some changes are
obvious after first looking at its ui
which is now missing a button for
self-repair instead bastion's alt-fire
ability sends out an explosive orb that
can bounce off of surfaces and stick to
players making it perfect for spamming
into choke points for area denial the
robot's regular gun has also changed
firing at a lower rate but losing all of
its spread making it kind of a dmr for
players to pick at enemies with the
heroes ultimate now transforms it into
an artillery cannon that can fire three
explosive shells anywhere on the map
fashion can now move while transform
turning the character into a roving
gatling gun the ability does have a cool
down now to keep it at least a little
more balanced
if you're a bastion or a sombra maine
let me know what you think about these
changes and if you're not then who is
your main and what kind of changes do
you want to see them get in overwatch
too let me know in the comments below
and of course leave a like and subscribe
so you don't miss your next gamespot
news update thank you so much for
watching and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you